We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. 99% of car trips in the US end in a free parking space. But if there's one thing that urban planning and parking guru Donald Schupe wants you to understand,
我们得到了来自加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、环境和教育方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗马·马斯。美国99%的汽车出行都以免费停车位结束。但是，如果城市规划和停车专家唐纳德·舒普有一件事希望你明白的话，
it's that so-called free parking is never free. May every time you go to a grocery store, a movie theater, a restaurant, everything you do has a bit of the cost of parking and beddative. Everything except one thing. Chap in your roll is driver. In the suburban environment, free parking is a given. Having a massive tarmac that can comfortably fit
那就是所谓的免费停车从来都不是免费的。事实上，每次你去杂货店、电影院、餐馆，你做的每一件事都包含了一点嵌入的停车成本。除了驾驶员自己的角色之外，一切皆是如此。在郊区环境中，免费停车是理所当然的。拥有一个可以舒适容纳大量汽车甚至能让波音747降落的巨型沥青停车场，是郊区景观的巨大组成部分。但即使在城市地区，我们也在补贴付费停车位，因为它们的租金低于市场价值。
a fleet of cars and also land a 747 is a huge part of the suburban landscape. But even in urban areas, we are subsidizing paid parking spaces because the rent on them is below market value. We also collectively pay for parking with time, cruising for parking, waste time. We've all done it. You go to a place and you see the prices of Wall Street parking.
我们还集体为停车支付了时间成本，寻找停车位浪费了时间。我们都做过这种事。你去一个地方，看到华尔街停车场的收费可能是每小时5美元，而街边停车位是每小时50美分。好吧，你会绕着街区转圈，直到看到有人把车开走。是的，因为在停车场停车是失败者的行为。如果你这么做，其他人也可能在这么做，这些加起来数目可观。唐纳德·舒普研究了加州大学洛杉矶分校附近15个街区商业区的寻找停车位现象，发现一年内因寻找停车位而行驶的车辆里程
It's maybe $5 an hour, and it's 50 cents an hour on the street. Well, you'll circle the block until you see somebody going out. Yeah, because parking in a lot is for quitters. If you do it, everybody else is probably doing it and it all adds up. Donald Schoep studied the amount of cruising for parking in the 15 block business district near UCLA and found that in a year the vehicle miles
几乎达到了一百万英里。这相当于四次登月之旅，或者绕地球36圈。寻找停车位和双排停车会减缓公共交通的速度，并危及骑自行车者和行人的安全，这种情况到处都在发生。没有人计算过所有这些停车位供应管理不善的成本。但旧金山正准备成为第一座良好管理停车位的大城市。我叫杰伊·普里米斯。
Travelled while cruising for parking was almost a million miles That's four trips to the moon or 36 trips around the earth cruising for parking and double parking slows public transit In dangerous bicyclers and pedestrians, and that is happening everywhere. Nobody has counted the costs of all this mismanagement for a parking supply. But San Francisco is looking to be the first major city to manage parking well. My name is Jay Primis.
我是旧金山交通局SF Park项目的经理。全新的SF Park项目使用传感器和联网路边停车计时器，随着时间动态调整停车价格。核心要素是传感器，它能反馈汽车是否实际停在那里的数据。我们将首次了解街道上正在发生的事情。利用这些传感器数据，停车管理局开始进行调整。传感器将实时数据反馈回总部，新的定价
I'm the manager of SF Park for the San Francisco MTA. The new SF Park project uses sensors and networked meters to dynamically adjust parking prices over time. The key ingredient is the sensor, which sends back data about whether or not a car is actually there. For the first time, we're going to know what's happening on the street. And with that sensor data, the parking authority starts adjusting. The sensors give real-time data back to headquarters and the new pricing
会为下一个月进行校准。这是需求响应定价。一天中的不同时段价格会上升，而交通较少街区的停车计时器价格可能会下降，以吸引人们把车停在那里并步行一小段路。但这不仅仅关于停车。SF Park旨在打造设计更好的城市。如今，许多城市都对减少温室气体排放和交通拥堵感兴趣。这是任何城市首次尝试采用基于停车的方法来进行交通拥堵管理。这对开车的人来说是好事，但对那些坐公交车正努力下班回家的人来说尤其重要，这样公交车就会快得多，也更
is calibrated for the next month. It's demand-responsive pricing. Different times the day make up in price and meters in less traffic neighborhoods may go down to entice people to park there and walk a little farther. But this isn't just about parking. SF Park is about making a better designed city. Lots of cities these days are interested in reducing greenhouse gas emissions and congestion. This is the first time that any city has tested out a parking-based approach to congestion management. That's good for people who drive, but it's really important for people who are on the bus and just trying to get home from work so that the bus is much faster and more
可靠。目标是保持持续的停车可用性，每个街区都有一个空车位，这样人们可以更快地停好车，而不会在街区里转圈排放毒气。而且这不仅限于街边停车。城市中车库的停车定价也将进行动态调整。街边计时停车场的停车价格与停车场或车库的停车价格之间没有必然联系。事实上，在停车场或车库停车通常比在路边计时器停车更贵，而这恰恰与应有的情况相反。该计划旨在改变这种关系，让在停车场和
reliable. The goal is to have constant parking availability, one open space for every block so that people get in a space faster and aren't circling the block in their toxins-buing death machines. And it's not just street parking. Pricing in the city on garages will also be dynamically adjusted too. There's no relation between the price of parking on street at meters and parking in a lot of garage. In fact, it's usually more expensive to park in a parking price of parking on street at meters and parking in a lot of garage In fact, it's usually more expensive to park in a parking lot of garage rather than at the meter and that's just the opposite of how it should be. The plan is to change that relationship make it cheaper to park in the lots and
车库停车更便宜，从而吸引更多人直接前往那些停车场和车库，为那些真正重视路边停车位的人保留这些路边车位。我认为关于SF Park获得最多媒体关注的是所有关于停车可用性的数据，公众都可以访问。而这给人的印象是一些精通技术的超级用户不断检查他们的 iPhone 来寻找停车位，而不是注意他们的驾驶路况。如果你想象一下，这会让人感到害怕，并且会产生比解决的问题更多的问题。但我认为这是错误的印象。如果成功的话（这是一个很大的假设），并且市场为停车位设定了正确的价值，
grudges to attract more people, just go straight to those lots and grudges, keeping those on-street spaces available for those who really value them. I think it's been getting the most press about SF Park is all the data about parking availability that will be accessible by the public. And the image is some tech savvy super user who is constantly checking their iPhone to find a parking space instead of watching where they're driving. Which if you picture it for a second is terrifying and would create more problems than it solves. But I think this is the wrong image. If successful, and it's a big if, and the market sets the right value for a parking space,
你将永远不会用 iPhone 寻找停车位，因为同样地，目标是每个街区有一个空车位，这意味着总会有停车位可用。根本不需要搜索。你用 iPhone 做的事情是弄清楚在你离开家之前它要花多少钱，你可以在那时决定是走路还是坐公交车而不是开车。关键在于，你不需要了解任何信息就能更轻松地停车。就像最好的设计一样，只有在你不需要为之付出努力时它才起作用。这说得通吧？
you will never look for parking with your iPhone, because again, the goal is one open space per block, meaning there will always be parking available. There is no searching. The things you use your iPhone for is finding out how much it'll cost before you leave the house, where you can decide then if it's better to walk or ride the bus instead of drive. The key is that you don't have to know anything to have an easier time parking. Like the best design, it only works if you don't have to work to make it work. That made sense, right?
“99%隐形”由我罗马·马斯制作，并得到了Lunar的支持。它是KALW、美国建筑师协会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。请访问 99%invisible.org 了解更多信息。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
99% Invisible is produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architect San Francisco in the Center for Architecture and Design. Find out more at 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99% Invisible》由我罗曼·马斯制作，Lunar 支持。这是 KALW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。请访问 99%invisible.org 了解更多信息。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。